welcome to the meeting of the executive
committee I must now read out the
emergency evacuation
announcements there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest exit please use either
the fire exit through the main doors of
the hall or the fire exit in the store
room adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance of
the building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until still given permission to
do so by Council staff please note the
this meeting will be live
streamed please switch off mobile phones
or turn them to silent
special mention for members members your
voice will only be captured on live
stream when your microphone is switched
on so please remember to switch your
microphone on when you're invited to
speak and switch it off again when
you're not speaking and I am the worst
offender and I tell you that now but
I'll do my
best thank you item one apologies for
absence I have apologies for absence
from councelor EES and councelor
Stanley nonmembers attending I have
councelor Mrs mcferson thank
you we have the minutes of the meeting
held on the 16th of
November I believe you've all have
copies of the
minutes can
I sign the minutes as having been agreed
please thank
you item four to receive Declarations of
interest there are
none questions on notice from counselors
there are
none item
six matters referred to the executive
and reports from other
committees uh we have 6.1 report of the
overview and scrutiny committee on
highways
ranges councilor Mrs mcperson your chair
of the on committee will you please now
introduce your report thank you thank
you chairman members of the executive
you will have the report from the
overviewing scrutiny Committee in front
of
you to give a brief overview Essex
County Council for seven years funded
Rochford Council High ways Rangers
service Essex County Council has now
ceased funding this valuable
service at the on meeting overview and
scrutiny I should say meeting on the 2nd
of November this item was debated for
some time it was pointed out that ESS
County Council is cutting this service
even though it's their statutory
Duty which puts our residents at risk
some simple examples were given such as
verges at
Junctions overgrowth growth near
schools there was the mention of double
taxation it was discussed as our
residents pay Essex County Council to
keep our highways
safe it is Essex County council's
statutory duty to maintain our highways
to a safe standard
it is quite clear they often fall very
short on this the committee debated for
some time the ESS County council's
decision to stop funding this valuable
service but one thing that the committee
was all agreed on is how this will
affect our residents
safety a difficult dilemma was put to
the overview and scrutiny committee and
now sits with yourselves it is not our
statutory
Duty however our residents do not care
who does the service they just want the
HED rows and overgrowth cleared our
residents just want safe highways and
Pathways so this probably led to the
fact that the overview and scrutiny
committee made up of each and every
party with one independent non-aligned
member voted in unanimously for the
proposal in front of you
tonight that is to continue the highway
Ranger service to fund the service via
the financial savings as outlined in
paragraph 1.2 of the report or
alternative means thank you
chairman thank you Mrs
Merson um members are there any
questions you wish to ask councilor Mrs
mcperson
councelor
[Music]
uh thank you chair I'm not sure it's a
question at the moment but um I'll frame
it as a question um do you consider that
the savings that have been
identified are permanent
savings moving
forward I think councelor Hoy you
probably know the answer to that
question no I
don't right thank
you council Mrs
Wilson hello thank you chair um I can
see under uh paragraph 1.9 table one for
the approved step funding
allocation um some of that um has been
whilst not committed is currently being
looked at Works being carried out so
although it says not committed at the
moment um there are plans in progress
for some of this I'm also awaiting um
exam act figures so if uh the set
funding is being looked at um I'd like
that taken away and uh discuss
separately please if that's possible
thank
you thank you councilor Wilson I believe
I believe the recommendation does um
take account of um your thoughts by
speaking of alternative means so it's
recognized are there any more questions
of council Mrs M
First Council thank
you thank you chairman
um thank you councilor mcferson um this
is a I don't really know if I should
have declared an interest because I was
um the me uh County member that called
this decision by essics into our own
place scrutiny committee do I have to no
okay
um you say that it's a statutory
Duty has in your um examination of this
did you look at the legal basis that
Essex County Council should deliver this
service as a statutory Duty and would it
be something that if it is a legal
obligation that the council could have
considered a legal challenge to Essex
County Council on this issue
thanks um first of all uh thank you
Council newort for calling that item in
at County um I'm glad that it is going
to be reviewed and I believe that that
is still the case that it is under
review
um the statutory
duty is how wide you look at their
statute to duty of keeping our Highway
safe and what is your bar that you set
against Essex County council's Bar I
think theirs is quite low I think most
of the general public um as they will
say the average Gentleman on the bus
would think they would prefer it high
that verges are cut that people can see
if children are walking long Pathways I
think that that's acceptable however I
will ask Marcus to step in because we
did actually discuss or ask the question
around going down the legal route thank
you Council M person I I will introduce
speakers not yourself thank you my
apologies chairman very
much do you wish to follow up on that
Council um thank you chairman um I would
be interested in whether or not the
council could make a legal challenge if
that is a
possibility um as has already been
identified I don't think the funding is
sustainable that we see in this report
and I think we do need to look at other
options so I'll leave that with you
[Music]
chairman thank
you I'll there any further questions for
council Mrs mcperson if not I'll say
thank you for coming along and thank you
for presenting your report and thank you
for answering those question questions
um we do have two officers here who have
been involved um in in this matter um Mr
hotton and indeed Mr Summers so I'll
invite um Mr hton first if he wishes to
add anything to the introduction that's
been made by councilor Mrs
mcferson good evening members I think
there's much more to you uh you cover it
quite comprehensively so it's uh I think
just down to touching on the question of
legality I think um the issue is that
obviously ethics are confident that
they're discharging their Duty so until
um you get evidence that they're not
discharging their Duty do you really
have a case to answer so at this state
at this point in time you'd be you'd be
trying to say we we think your um
provision is inadequate but we've not
given them a chance to be inade
inadequate if that makes sense
so you you be You' be trying to preempt
uh a lack of service which they're
saying they can actually cover with the
resource they've got so so you'd have to
allow it to fail before you could do
so thank you Mr
hon members you're you're aware that the
overview and scrutiny committee asked me
as leader to write to the cabinet member
for highways and it is now councelor Tom
Cunningham uh Mr Cunningham didn't reply
immediately but he replied after I
chased him and he has certainly amongst
other things confirmed that the decision
not to fund the highway ranges at the
district council's currently
stands as I understand it there may be
the possibility that a thirdparty
contractor may fill that um that
obligation and otherwise
um the matter is likely to return to the
situation that I was in as a ward
councelor before high rate ranges
existed of having to report these these
issues of overgrown Hedges to Essence
County Council who in turn um either had
resources available or they turned to
the landowner to actually correct the
position so I believe i' I've culated
that reply from Council cing to all of
you Mr Summers um Mr Summers is here and
he also been involved in the matter of
investigating issues on the highway
ranges provision have you anything to
add
sir thank you chair no I I don't think
there's anything further to add at this
point Thank
you thank you Mr Summers in which case I
now take it to to um the
recommendation the recommendation is as
printed I'm now
inviting
um opinion
debate further recommendation councilor
H thank you
chairman yes it was interesting at
essics today there were questions around
Hedges and grass cutting um and about
whether it's the words we're using is
safe or
dangerous um and it was quite clear from
the answers councelor Cunningham gave
that there is there are no resources or
eics to cut anything we were one of the
questions was around private land owners
and getting them to cut their own Hedges
and even then we were told that there
are not resources in our enforcement
team at Essex to to enforce
them to cut even and that it should
perhaps be let to local members and
Parish councils to chase up these local
people so I think we're not going to get
anywhere at essic um I
myself like the highway Ranger service I
think they do a good job and I think the
service they provide is needed
unfortunately essics are refusing to
fund the
service um I would take advice on this
from officers look at Mr Summers um I
feel that the
recommendation that we are putting
forward should be slightly different to
the one that's been recommended by
overview and
scrutiny
um because I think that if we want a
highways Ranger service we should not be
scrabbling around year on year to see
where we can fund it from I think if
we're going to do it we need to know we
can fund it for three years at a time at
least
so my recomendation would be to it would
i' change the I don't know how to do
this which I've asked for advice is to
change the two recommendations to a
recomend recommendation to investigate
how the continued funding of the
highways Ranger service can be made
through the budget process by by adding
this into the current budget process to
see where we can have permanent funding
for it if
possible that's where I'm leaving is
that understandable by the chairman and
by Mr Summers it it's understandable by
by myself I'm concerned that our
officers have this properly for the
minute because that's a proposal from
yourself is there a seconder for that
proposal I've got a number of hands I
think council Mrs Wilson was marginally
F first um it'll be fingers on buzzers
next
next so we have a seconded um proposal
to consider let me see if I get this
right to consider longer term
sustainable funding which should
commence in the process of the
budget yes sorry yes consideration of
Investigation of is that correct yes I
used the word investigate yes you did
yeah
members do you wish to speak to the
proposal the
recommendation Council
Newport
I I'd like to put a further
recommendation forward as well can I do
that chairman so is that an amendment to
my no
[Music]
proposal additional is it okay if I
chair this meeting thank
you just just
checking
um are you adding Council a new board to
that
recommendation or are you seeking to
replace it no I want to add an
additional
recommendation would you like to State
yeah um the Rochford District Council
establishes whether Essex County
Council are fulfilling their legal or
statutary
Duty
um to carry
[Music]
out appropriate Highway
Maintenance C will you accept that as
part of your
recommendation I am happy too if the
secondary is Happ to as well does
councelor Mrs
Wilson also agree yes thank
you that case members you invited to
speak to a recommendation in two parts
in replacement of the printed
recommendation from overview and
scrutiny
committee
[Music]
okay council Mrs goody I think it's key
that we do take up the the mantle and
run with what we've put forward because
uh we can't risk the safety of our
residents and and that's what we're
doing by doing nothing so thank
you Mrs
Wilson thank you chair um I Echo what
councilor goodin has just said um as
much as um I will be honest with you I'm
torn with this because I don't like
paying twice for something but actually
the point that counselor uh befon said
in that basically uh it's what residents
expect um I do think it's such an
essential um piece of work that needs to
be carried out for safe not just for
safety reasons but we don't want our
district to look shoddy we've we've
spent a lot of time and effort making
sure we look as smart and presentable as
we can I don't want Rockford's
reputation to go downhill so there are
many many reasons and I could go on
forever however chair I won't so thank
you thank you for sparing
me any uh any further comments
okay in which case um can we oh sorry
councilor Williams excuse me I didn't no
that's okay thank you chairman I would
just like clarification on what the full
recommendation would be now if that's
possible I'm glad you asked that that
was the next thing I wish to do
so can you read out please the
recommendation in two parts thank
you to investigate longer term
sustainable funding for the highr rang
highr Ranger Service as part of the 2425
budget process and that um Rood District
Council establishes whether Essex County
Council are fulfilling their statutary
duty to carry out appropriate Highway
Maintenance thank you I'll now place
that recommendation to the vote those in
favor please
indicate that is a unanimous decision
thank you very
much all we now move members to item
seven which is has a rather cryptic but
um understandable report on I call it
gbus and eco4
schemes
and I understand that Council Hoy will
will um introduce this report thank
you thank you
chairman um after I've introduced report
um if the chairman wants to ask the
officer to speak I'm sure he can add to
the information I'm giv as well that's
all this is regarding the Great British
insallation and the energy
company obligation
schemes um the purpose of the report is
is firstly
to propose the recommendation in R1
which is to publish a statement of
intent as set out in appendic one and
administer the eco4 and jbus
schemes
um
the the reason for this is for as it
says in 1.1 in order for households to
access
the schemes the council must State
publicly through a statement of intent
which is in appendix one the criteria it
intends to adopt to identify households
that meet the elig eligibility
criteria this recommendation will
confirm our inent as the council to take
part in these schemes and allows those
energy suppliers who are eligible to
work with eligible residents there a lot
of eligible there um I think the report
itself is self-explanatory this will
allow us to move towards carbon
neutrality with our residents as well as
with the council and we are essentially
acting as a conduit for these grants
thank
you members I'll ask Mr hotton whether
he wishes to to add to the introduction
given by the lead member thank
you good evening members again um so I
think just to add that the statement of
intent allows us have a wider criteria
than than without the statement of
intent so I think in many ways the
scheme runs um without that statement of
intent as well but we do not administer
the scheme so people could directly
apply to um the administrator which is
off gim to uh to apply for funds but
this is allows us to act as a conjur for
the for the kind of administration and
dealing with the applications so we
actually sort of um refer them on to for
consideration but it also allows you to
have a wider net I think I think just
reading between the lines I think these
schemes have been running out for about
10 years but they find them quite hard
to reach the people actually are legible
for the schemes so I think what they've
tried to do is look to sort of a more
local administrative approach and so
really um the reason it's coming here
today is for that statement of intent I
think it wasn't for that we we could we
could run this without that anyway thank
you right I'm opening it to questions
from Members Council Newport You'
indicated
thank you chairman well I think we
should um obviously this is this this is
a good scheme that will um benefit many
people especially those on low incomes
by the looks of things just one question
do we already have a relationship with
um Aaron
and I've I've never seen any sort of
performance or or and the only concern I
may possibly have is any reputation
damage that could occur to Rochford
District Council um working with that
provider so I just seeking reassurance
really on on that thank
you so um in an earlier um version of
this the eco3 rather than the eco4 uh um
rra Council along with another um with a
Consortium of council signed up with
Aaron to deliver the eco3 um scheme um
the the agreement of that that contract
binds us into about another 12 months of
delivering this type of scheme so
although this is a new tranch of funding
um we are s of contractually bound into
Aon so they delivered previously for us
um there has been I would say
reputational concerns but they are
slightly slow the box to begin with but
I think that's been addressed uh as as
the last trun of funding came through so
eco4 I think you know the view is that
they should be able to live this quite
quite
sufficiently yes of course
thank you chairman um in terms of um any
resource from our council is that is
that none or do we have is there any
resource implications of this
scheme so there's a administrative sort
of referral resources are required but
we have the sort of domestic Energy
Efficiency officer who whose post is is
designed for this sort of thing so at
this time um the officer is uh
undertaking the
household upgrade grants hug um scheme
uh and there's again a very similar
thing referrals so examples the park
homes referrals had 50 50 Park Homes go
through that scheme is now being rolled
out so but but it's what that that that
um role is there for so it fits
perfectly with that
work thank you Mr hotton um counc Wilson
you were before Council
H
well Council hton was saying are you
agreeable to that Council gon thank you
yeah as I feel the questions could be
asked to me as well um I just want to
make it clear the the officer that Mr
Hon's referring to is a funded officer
by grant for specifically for this role
so if we didn't have the
officer we wouldn't have any the money
to fund the officer so we've got the the
funding is specifically for the officer
and the officer is running out a number
of Grants and I think reputationally
there has been some I can't remember if
this same company or not mron but I know
the park home sites in hridge
particularly have have had insulation
GRE and the um reputation of that
supplier is is high they is all had very
good
reports thank you councelor H councilor
Mrs Wilson your turn thank you for
waiting thank you chair I'm very patient
person um I think this uh scheme is a
really really good idea um I have two
questions chair for um councelor H or
Marcus hton um I don't mind your answers
um it's not clear to me as to how many
residents this scheme will help um and I
felt that that was quite quite important
um it was for me to understand you know
how how many people were likely to help
and also do we know do we know um when
the scheme is successfully rolled out
exactly what the impact on Rocha
District Council achieving Net Zero will
be thank
you I I don't know which of you is going
to take I just the question I just
indicated that mron can take that one to
start
with um I think the short answer is
we're not sure um and that's it's a um
there is not a set u amount
necessarily dedicated to to the rer
district so it's a national scheme I've
got it's um the home heating cost
reduction obligation that is requested
from each um major energy provider um
it's very formulaic I won't pretend I
think it might someone in White Hall has
you know sat in the darken room and come
up with the amounts um but it's very so
so that there is a report on how many
they have delivered but but it seems to
be harder to actually find how many are
left to uh how many of amount of
resources left available to to tap into
if that makes sense so I don't have
those that answer to the figure so it
could be um it could be 10 houses it
could be 40 houses I mean you know but I
don't have an exact figure I think it
depends also on on the cost of each
scheme so I think it's done on pricing
and so I think at times it's really the
solution for each property that comes
along so I think it's quite hard to
specify the amounts but certainly um we
can provide uh monthly updates on what
has been done and the carbon s of sort
of benefits from that going
forward that's M Wilson thank you chair
may I ask Marcus a other
question I just clarify the answer with
Marcus that is giving me one of thank
you sorry Marcus
um so from what you've just said for our
residents is it first come first serve
if it's a nationally rolled out scheme
if we don't get in quicker we likely to
have missed the opportunity for our
residents you're going to have to excuse
me I'm failing to understand
how how the impact and the positive um
attributions of this will will be for
for us and our residents thank
you I think I think some the simple
answer is yes I mean certainly you know
the best thing get applications in
sooner than later um but there are a
number of schemes out there um so you
know um optimistically if if you fail on
one there may well be another that that
you could apply to but I think you know
um certainly if they contact sort of
domestic uh domestic Energy Efficiency
officer I have to keep remember the
words myself um then then someone would
be gladly give some advice to people if
they wish
to and Marcus sorry my my final point
Sorry chair my final point is um those
monthly reports I think would be really
useful really informative if that could
be arranged that would be great thank
you yeah can we take that as a minuted
action please to be circulated to all
members of the
council thank
you Council Miss Newport thank
you thank you chair um my question is
regarding the um Grant funded
officer is there any further cost
implications to the council other than
um what's already covered by the the
grant funded officer or the officer that
that's funded by the grant if that makes
sense thank
you no none
whatsoever thank
you are there any further questions
councilor Gooding thank
you can I just ask um if the officer is
able to give us a a Time on the how long
the scheme will take for completion so
if it's on first come first sered basis
is it just running for the year for six
months
sorry I'd be reluctant to to answer now
I think as we discussed and noted the
idea of a monthly report I think will
gladly provide a sort of monthly um sort
of briefing note to send around to
members any further
questions no further
clarifications
in which
case members we have a
recommendation a recommendation is only
R1 it's to publish the statement of
intent as set out in appendix one and I
hope you've all looked at appendix one
because it does go on a little bit and
administer eco4 and gbus
schemes do we have a proposal for that
recommendation councelor H second counc
good
right I'll take an indication please by
a vote of hands with those in
favor believe that's unanimous as well
thank you
members members we now move to item
8 section 106 report quarterly position
statement Mr Goody Mr Goodman is here
and um be before Council Hoy I think
I'll ask Daniel Goodman to introduce the
report thank you very
much thank you chairman uh so members uh
this is a quarterly position statement
on the council's latest section 106
position uh so uh for any members who
aren't aware but I'm sure you all are
the council collects uh Financial
contributions from local developments
via 106 legal agreements uh typically
those section 106 contributions are
there to mitigate the impact of the
development so could be for uh local
Open Spaces uh could be for education
and so on so the position statement is
at 1st of October 2023 and as said out
in the report at that time the council
held
881 537 95 in contributions towards
projects over which it has discretion I
won't read them item by item but if any
members do have any questions around
individual items I'm happy to come back
to that and within the report there's
also uh an update on positive progress
that has been made towards spend of a
number of these
contributions uh including some funding
uh that was spent towards uh do flooring
for the main hall and Studio Halls at
Clem Hall Leisure Center some funding
that was used to uh fund the dredging of
Roth Brook some funding that's been
allocated to escape parks subject to
Executive approval um and some other
um updates which uh are subject to
quotes and no doubt will come forward
for decisions where
relevant the uh main thing that I would
say that I didn't say at the start was
that this only covers contributions that
are due to rer District Council so uh
you will be aware that a number of
contributions go to SS County Council
they are in charge of their own
monitoring uh which we do receive ad hoc
updates from from but um not at the
regularity in order to be able to
include them in this report
regrettably uh the last thing I would
say members before pausing is that um
there are also a number of contributions
set out in this report which uh no firm
update has been provided since 2022 and
the typical reason for that is either
that uh the amount of funding isn't
sufficient to deliver the project in its
entirety and hence there is um there is
uh putting on hold if you like until
further funding can be achieved or
because uh a suitable project is still
in the pipeline and not ready yet for
quotes or the like uh the report is for
information more than happy to take
questions VI yourself chairman thank you
thank you Mr Gman um councelor Hoy do
you want to add anything to the
introduction um yeah um I'll introduce
my introduction um which is probably the
same as um Mr Goodman's I I would just
add that um this item fell off the
agenda of the executive it used to be
quarterly and I think it's was missed a
couple of times so this is now being
brought back and it is under the lead
membership of the of Finance at this
moment to make sure this report is is
brought forward and is responsible to
make sure it's brought forward and dealt
with
um in addition to the items that um Mr
Goodman mentioned there has been contact
made I know that um an officer of eics
has made contact with Mr Goodman about
ways that some of the health care
spending could be
utilized
um with digital inclusivity I think it
is as as a a further way of um people to
access their medical services in the in
the area and also understand that
councelor Steptoe at Essex through his
Essex role has also spoken to the
scrutiny panel there about how
now all councils can better manage their
section 106 money and actually spend it
which is what it's there for so that
that's the only other other updates I'd
put to that thank you Council I think um
R would do a pretty good job myself um
not sure that it can be much added to
the efficiency um of um officers to
recognize and to organize appropriate
projects
nevertheless um I was interested to hear
that asex are interested
in being involved in the spending of the
provisions to the
NHS I'm not sure I understand that
because the provision is made to the NHS
in their
discretion can you add anything to my
[Music]
misunderstanding Ence canate that
officer ESS at Essex can liaz with the
NHS to to have money spent they can liaz
with GP surgeries to see if they can
utilize the money more efficiently or in
a way that will allow them to to have
access to more patients some of the
issues around the health care
contribution is that
it's it's generally for Capital items
and it's not enough for surgeries to
expand or to build I mean that's
certainly the case in holbridge as I
understand at the moment so if there is
a way to spend this on capsule items
which can be encouraged and and served
by Essex to help the individual GP
surges putting putting bids for this
money then that would be very helpful
and that's the sort of work I'm
saying it's to to some of this
Healthcare money has been there for
quite a while and it's not being
spent so that's a particular Department
of ESS County Council is
it it's a particular Department of FS
County Council I believe under Luis
McKinley Council
McKinley thank you Council Hoy excuse me
for asking loads of questions members
but that was of great interest to
me C
newort thank you chairman um I just want
to check on um page
8.12 um item 15 on the accuracy of
the it's got AE in repayment terms but I
don't I strictly know if that heading is
uh accurate in because I understand and
Marcus hton might be able to help with
this item this is about the off-site
flood mitigation contribution and the
terms around that payment and it's got
here that repayment terms are not
applicable but we can actually lose that
money if it's not spent within a certain
period of time would that not detail not
be put in
there um either of you could answer that
but and also just a quick query on item
17 on the fairways Garden Center is that
section 106 actually being
signed as that site is being brought
forward because as far as I knew that
wasn't coming forward thanks I think Mr
Goodman will take in order thank you
thank you Council newort and thank you
uh chairman I'm very happy to defer to
Mr hton if if I'm proven wrong my my
understanding around the offsite flood
mitigation contribution was that um it
is subject to a draw drown protocol in
the sense that um there needs to be an
advancement of an idea in order to be
able to draw down that money in chunks
whereas a traditional section 106
contribution is paid Come What May and
therefore is repaid if it's not spent so
there's a possibility that we are both
correct in the sense that if that money
was drawn down and then not spent it may
well then be repaid but I believe that
it's only drawn down subject to an the
advancement of a project and therefore
it's not as it's not subject to the draw
down protocol in the same way as a pot
of money that could just sit there
without um any attention to it if that
if that makes sense on your other
question councelor Newport um
Fairways Garden Center is a slightly
interesting one my understanding is that
the section 106 sat unsigned for a
period of time following the resolution
from development committee but it has
been revived if that's the right word
and now signed and so that permission
has not ever expired because the expiry
of the permission comes three years
after the date of the planning
permission and the planning permission
was only issued after the 106 was signed
so I'm not a lawyer and I I won't get
into anything around abandonment of 106
and everything else but just to confirm
to you that that 106 agreement has been
signed fairly recently in the last six
months I believe and therefore we are
bound I suppose to consider that
permission as live and that 106
agreement as live um until such time as
we hear otherwise thank
you could I ask if Mr hton can add
anything to either case or the first Cas
is the most most
likely thank you so I think regarding I
um Mr Goodman's uh sort of explanation
of the funding is accurate um but that I
think country of indicated that they are
um mindful to take a lighter touch on
this and will allow us to almost um put
forward a a sort of a broader scheme of
U mitigation for for flooding and and
allows to draw down the the entirety of
the funding and and hold on to that so
so that the deadlines do not slip so
they they they're quite Kean for us to
access the funding and they're being
quite sort of flexible on that approach
so I think we should be able to secure
that I think that's councel nle can I
just ask whether that answers your
questions yes I think councilor CPS is
to add to it thank you chairman thank
you I'll let councelor cryp add when his
turn comes
uh councelor
Gooding thank you chair um I was just
looking at the the the funding for the
land Pon Chase um nursery and this has
been available since 2018 so that's five
years are we in excess of the time there
because um the the suggestion that um
Council Hoy has come up with I wonder
for the health and communities um
directorate um if we could utilize These
funds by working in partnership with
essics as Council Hoya suggested um it
would be good use of the the
funds beneficial for the
residents I'm not sure if that was a
question of council Hoy or question of
the
offices um the um refundable date is
2028 so I think it's still well within
time
limits about the question
about working with the appropriate
department at ess6 County Council was
the open one how should we carry that
forward that would be carried forward as
a matter of working with Essex County
Council this is one of the the key ones
which has been looked at anyway within
Hawley so it's an action on the office
the office this is at the very early
stages
and there's no there's no nothing formal
in place yet but that's what we're
working on and I know that Mr Goodman's
been contacted by the officer of
essic already if he remembers yes and um
we just both need to follow up to get
that moving okay let's make that an
appropriate minuted action um with Mr
Goodman for the moment and for the
future with the community's directorate
thank you
all right councelor
CS thank you chair Marcus um just to
clarify that uh offsite flood mitigation
I put forward a proposal which was by
annual dredging of the brook um in order
to spread the money far enough to be
effective over a period of time and that
threatened to overrun what was the
original deadline uh on the 106 money
and I know you've said Countryside of
are favorable to a softer touch but I
actually add confirmation that to my
scheme that I put forward uh so if you
could chase that up for me and do me
something thank
you thank you councelor Crips that's
another minuted action for the offices
thank
you I think I've run out of names at
this point unless I'm
mistaken that report um members is for
noting and I'd like to uh thank Mr
Goodman for revising it several times at
the request of my request for detail
which I know has been very useful to
members so thank you very much for
that so we've noted
it agreed noted thank
you we now move to item
nine the withdrawal withdrawal from the
opportunity south essic or otherwise I
call it
OC to consider the report of the
executive lead member for resources
climate change and economy recommending
the council withdraw support and funding
for the Federated Business board
opportunity south essic from the 31st of
March
24 I'm not sure whether to ask the
executive
member or Mr Goodman let's
take Mr
Goodman thank you
chairman as said out in the reports
members this report is recommending that
the council withdraws support and
funding for the Federated business
support uh board opportunity south
essics or Os from 31st March
2024 so members may be aware but the
government have taken a decision to
essentially remove the current tier um
of business
uh Support Agency or business lead
agency which are local Enterprise
Partnerships so rodford District Falls
within the southeast local Enterprise
partnership otherwise known as celup
which will cease to exist from the 1st
of April
2024 with the powers that were
previously held by L uh leps uh now
being moved to Upper tier authorities so
for Rochford that will be ATS County
council members may be aware but um leps
often have local Federated business
boards which are made up of local
authorities and local Business Leaders
so Rochford District makes a financial R
Council makes a financial contribution
to opportunity South Essex which covers
the traditional South Essex local
authorities and has a board that's made
up of local Business Leaders it has an
annual budget um and the local
authorities in South Essex are the
largest contributors to that
budget however in light of the
government's decision to uh remove the
tier that leps currently make up and to
provide um to move those powers to Upper
tier authorities there is now an
opportunity to review the existing
federative business board
structure um in this case what is being
recommended to you members is that the
council like other local authorities
across South fic withdraws its support
and funding from opportunity south ess6
from the 31st of March 2024 which is
also the date uh the day before um the
let power is being transferred to the
Essex County Council there may be a
future uh proposed that comes before you
for a uh quazi replacement or or
suitable alternative replacement for osc
um however the decision as I say before
you today is to U withdraw um the
council support and financial
contribution from osc from March it is
also worth saying that this was
considered by the south council's joint
committee and that they made this
recommendation to us uh we are
representing that recommendation to you
now thank
you thank you Mr
Gman does council H wish to add
anything no I think Mr Goodman said
everything I could
say thank you uh any questions
members council Mrs newort thank you
chair what happens if we want get back
in it can we thank
you sorry there was a not so people who
were hearing may not have understand the
answer to that question which I take was
it doesn't exist anymore effectively I
think the correction is it won't exist
anymore dissolve it will have will have
dissolved and been
replaced and most likely it will also
appear in some way as to the part of s
greater essics in due
course members um looks like we got two
recommendations here um are you
agreeable to taking them as one in one
vote okay R1 I'll read it read them out
um that the council withdraws its
support
from let me get this correct that the
council withdraws its support to
opportunity South Essex from the 31st of
March
2024 under the terms of the relevant
agreement r two that the council
withdraws its £12,500
annual commitment to the osc from the
31st of March to
24 can I ask for those in favor of both
oh
proposal
was I think I should be proposing it as
it's com proposal for Council Hoy second
councilor Mr Newport thank
you those in favor of recommendations R1
and O2 taken
together that is unanimous as well thank
you very
much I always let myself down I get to
the last recommendation and
completely forget so thank you for a
reminder I've turned over the page can't
find anything but Mr Stevenson signature
so I'm going to call the meeting to a
conclusion at something
like 8 24 yeah thank you very much thank
you very much members thank you very
much officers for attending and
contributing thank you and thank you for
the